hello vilka men and that's about all the
German I know so so yes its CSS calm
2015 and I am so honored to be up here
and have been asked to help MC and help
host the event today and it's amazing
there's over 400 attendees today that's
incredible like thank you all for coming
here get around applause to yourselves
if you want yeah and this is the third
CSS confit you so css3 we're here we
finally met the spec and we're out there
now and this is part of we have people
here from over 13 countries by the way
if you all didn't know that coming from
all over Europe from Australia from
Zimbabwe I found out that's amazing
everyone came over here hear about some
CSS and css3 and the CSS comp is part of
the CSS conf organization now it's a
whole organization originally inspired
by Nicole Sullivan for CSS comp in
florida in 2011 our 2013 excuse me and
is expanded so far has inspired so many
other conferences so the past this past
year they've had CSS conf changed over
from Florida to New York where I'm from
and that was this past year it was an
amazing event and some multiple people
from which none of that are here today
as well we have CSS conf Australia which
I've heard and quoting here strongly
believe it might happen again maybe
around march or april of next year so
keep your eyes and ears open about for
that also last year was CSS calm oakland
that was a whole week of events called
jazz fest happened in oakland california
and amazing event and really inclusive
and diverse and it sounded like a lot of
fun and hopefully it might happen again
and then the next coming up conference
is this conf Asia this is actually part
of a big a 10-day event of 20 to 10 days
and 22 events it's happening on the 18th
is GSS conf the second one for Asia and
the next two days after that rjs comp
Asia for the fourth time and the 10 days
includes a web audio hack day a node
school and even a node bought sumo
battle so look forward to that and some
more upcoming ones maybe CSS common or
way no way yeah so that's happening so
if this uses comp Norway folks here you
Stan hey look at that so ya go
and maybe CSKA Budapest it's the best
yeah or yet today yeah and so today
we're here in amazing Berlin this is
actually my first time absolutely
outside the United States and it's been
an awesome week that I've been here it's
amazing to visit Berlin and see the
places and all the all the great food
and touristy things that I've been able
to do and great coffee by the way but
we're also hearing this amazing radio
systems boom I think I pronounced that
correctly ish and it may be wonder what
happened to the other four radio systems
I mean we're here the fourth way
especially the third one we're going to
keep in theme with three today and so r
audio system that I happen to be very
appropriate for the name maybe not
location or a waterworks factory for
those that don't get it try desert
speaking of dry humor and we're going to
go onto movie puns so Dhaka
so I wanted to look into the movie
trilogies inspired by css3 starting with
Mad Max with beyond pundir dome to give
you a little hint of what we're going
for today although as chrissy pointed it
out CSS com3 did not wait till the 4th
one to equal out as gender diversity and
get that going this event was almost
return of the JED if anyone and however
you couldn't make it this year so I came
up and took his place some of the people
the audience who might recognize that
this is actually the sixth movie
technically but if you look closely at
the third one it's actually returned to
the six so that's a little strange and
you'll see that in CSS as revenge of the
sixth and we're also in the EU in Europe
and so we want to show the European
movie series that have been inspired by
CSS including before midnight and our
favorite three color series of FFF and
also we had those old school movies I've
been really coming out but actually may
have kind of guess what's going on in
the future the good the bad and the in
line and I think one of Judge Smith's
personal favorites Indiana Jones and the
Last cascade so I believe it's happening
it's coming i mean CSS is dead if you've
heard from anyone i'm kidding it's just
God if speakers go on a little bit too
long today we're going to have to cut
them off for in other words at words end
oh yeah oh yeah one grown we got it and
also coming up in the future of CSS
might be the rising machines if anyone's
seen the grid io yet it's happening it's
they're taking over
and of course one of my favorite sci-fi
flicks matrix revolutions or with these
days matrix 3d revolutions of course
Michael Bay's always been a big fan of
CSS if y'all didn't know the
Transformers series has been one of my
favorites I was a little stretch and so
today there's me a lot going on and so I
want to go over the schedule real quick
as we had this morning me up here and we
have a couple speakers and then coffee
and then a couple speakers and then
lunch and then a couple speakers and
then more coffee and a couple speakers
then coffee and cake so the plan will
have closing remarks at a family photo
and dinner and another party right
before jazz comp day two and you can
keep track of all those sets this URL
and so I'd like to introduce our first
speaker now that that's all the way
she's coming from New York where I'm
from I've known her for quite a while
now and it's been a joy to hang out with
her in New York and all the events that
she's a part of she helps organize sask
humph which is coming up this year in
november in austin texas so keep their
eye has a half of that maybe head over
there she's also an organizer of the
premier SAS in front end meet up in New
York's Gotham sass and so now it's time
for viva la front end revolution with
cloudiness aha
you